who's gonna be more desperate in this
game between the 0-1 falcons who got
shredded defensively their offense
looked pretty damn good matt ryan had
450 passing yards cowboys
plotting offense on the final drive of
the game they just wasted the time they
had they never got in position to even
have a chance to get in field goal range
the offensive pass interference call
against michael gallup didn't help but
who's more desperate to win this one to
avoid going 0-2 peter
cowboys look the the falcons spent about
10 weeks last year desperate
so and what good did it do them you know
starting whatever it was one in seven
so i
they were desperate a whole bunch of
weeks in a row in my opinion
mike mccarthy this is one of the games
when you look at the schedule
that the dallas cowboys
i wouldn't say hey they really should
win i would say they have to win because
they don't have
i mean they don't have the hardest
schedule in the league
but this is one of those games that
you've got to win
and it's one of those games your offense
has to get healthy
and i guess i look at it and say you've
got
to get an advantage on this secondary
because to me
the atlanta secondary is where dak
prescott
uh cd lamb and these guys they have got
to
make hay because this is not a great
secondary they're rebuilding their
cornerback core
and this is a game that mike mccarthy
has got to pull out some of his uh
some of his a some of his tricks
that he and and jim hazlitt and his crew
studied in green bay for a year
i'll say this as it relates to
potentially winning the division i think
the falcons need this one more than the
cowboys because there's a good chance
washington's going to be one and one
after this weekend there's a good chance
the giants are going to be 0-2 good
chance the eagles are going to be 0-2 at
best 1-1 obviously the cowboys don't
begin to fall out of the race if they
lose if the falcons lose the saints are
most likely going to be 2-0 that's when
you start to fade away too early in the
season now as it relates to this funky
new wild card chase
i'd say the cowboys are a little more
desperate because that seventh spot
peter is going to be huge you don't want
to go down in the tiebreaker with the
falcons in the event that the cowboys
are jockeying for position for those
final three spots but as it relates to
winning a division i think the falcons
need this one more but uh from the just
the overall meeting your expectations
for the season
the cowboys start no and two yet again
they look great on paper and then we
start playing the games and they don't
live up to it all right the vikings and
the colts meeting in indianapolis both
teams oh and one a lot of people thought
the colts would be a super bowl
contender coming out of the afc the
vikings i thought would win the division
i don't think that after seeing what
aaron rodgers did to them who is more
desperate to get that win and avoid
falling to owen 2.
indianapolis
because there's already coming out of
this game look no matter what happens in
this game
no one is going to say
put uh
put kirk cousins on the bench it's not
gonna happen but if philip rivers throws
three passes to the vikings there's
gonna be a lot of people in indianapolis
who say hey philip rivers is what what
he thought we were
is what
we thought he was
and give us brissette because in some in
some cities the most popular guy is the
backup quarterback and right now i think
phillip rivers has to come out and give
the kind of performance
that philip rivers on a given sunday can
give
320 yards three touchdowns no turnovers
he needs that performance to show the
city of indianapolis to show his
teammates there's a reason
that chris ballard paid 25 million
dollars to get me
and this is a fascinating dilemma for
the colts because jacoby brissett's
making 15 million dollars a year he's in
the last year of his contract they did
that band-aid last year to settle it
down when they thought he was the guy
and he was the guy until he wasn't the
guy anymore but
would the colts
pivot quickly away from phillip rivers
when they've made that 25 million dollar
investment i remember when
phillip rivers drew brees and tom brady
all did the same deal basically one year
for 25 million although there are some
variations in the contracts they're all
getting 25 million this year i said
philip rivers should be wearing a ski
mask he does not fit with the drew brees
tom brady 25 million a year and if the
cults
struggle out of the gates
will they will they factor in the
investment in philip rivers
to justify giving him another chance and
you know the best way to approach
football is if you made a mistake don't
double down admit the mistake and move
on and yeah the vikings don't have to
worry about kirk cousins getting benched
because plan b is sean mannion that's
not happening but when he got jacoby
percent making 15 million
and you know what he did last year he
took the team to a 5-2 record before he
got the knee injury was never the same
after that peter i agree with you at
some point sooner rather than later
you're gonna have people clamoring for
percent to be under center if the colts
just can't win games with phillip rivers
it's not two weeks it's five weeks
it's you know frank reich is not going
to
uh i mean unless it's an absolute abject
disaster they're not going to think
about that yet they're going to give
philip rivers a real legitimate chance
um to pilot this team to the playoffs
and if
five or eight games in it's not
happening and they're you know they're
three under 500 or whatever then i could
see them pulling the plug but it's way
way too early to think about that
these two teams got well not these two
teams this quarterback faced the vikings
in december when he was with the
chargers and he threw three
interceptions now that was a chargers
home game which meant it was a vikings
road home game overtaken by vikings fans
so uh different circumstances now and
different defense for the vikings the
pass rush not nearly as potent with
denial hunter injured everson griffin
gone yannick and gawkway nicked up in
the first game and really wasn't able to
contribute the defensive backs a bunch
of young guys where mike zimmer is
rolling the dice so the opportunities
should be there for philip rivers in the
passing game he should be able to
navigate it without throwing in
interceptions if he does though peter i
you know whether it's week five week two
week three week whenever
it's not going to be too early to come
to the conclusion that that philip
rivers uh may be stuck around one year
too long that it's just not there for
him anymore and the two interceptions
against jacksonville were very very
concerning we'll see what he can do
against the vikings but you know i agree
with you the cults are uh a little more
desperate and i think from the viking
standpoint you know i look i i don't say
you can see the division title based on
one game but when the packers come in
and kick the crap out of you the way
they did and then you have to go play at
lambeau field later in the year for what
could be their first game of the season
with fans present you're going to get
swept by the packers most likely and if
you get swept by the packers your
chances of winning the division are
remote at this point this is about maybe
the vikings trying to get a wild card so
i think the colts who were right in the
thick of things in the afc south and
expected to win the division they can't
afford to go to owen 2.
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports